spent a little time yesterday talking
about a column on Yahoo Sports written
by Dan Wetzel and the title was college
football playoff doesn't need expansion
it needs reform and Dan Wetzel joins us
on the program good morning Dan how are
you I'm great thank you explain the
premise for your column that we don't
need expansion we need reform okay
simple this weekend is the first weekend
of the playoffs this weekend is the
postseason this is not regular season
for college football yet our first
weekend of the postseason consists of a
bunch of games that makes zero sense
okay first there call conference
championship we get these conferences
are already decided Alabama want it
clemson want it Oklahoma want it
Washington want it UCF want it there's
technically a tie between Ohio State
Northwestern but any known tiebreaker
other than the love of purple would go
to Ohio State so we're having
Championships that have already been
decided
it's like college basketball tournaments
they're fun they make a couple bucks but
that's it they don't get in the way of
the actual NCAA tournament now here they
do so if you take this we have Alabama
could lose this weekend and still
advance that's through first round your
playoff Clemens and could lose in still
advance Notre Dame doesn't have to play
this bunches of teams can win and not
advance it's a waste of time
if you just get rid of this and replace
it with a teen playoff for games and you
could have Conference champs and
whatever but you're getting at you know
Washington at Alabama and UCF at Clemson
and Ohio State at Notre Dame and
Oklahoma at Georgia you are now if
that's your slate this weekend the
country is fired up for college football
like that would be an absolutely awesome
for games this weekend and you would be
everyone be talking college football
everyone to be excited in and it would
make more money the games to be more
meaningful more historic you play them
on
campus everything would be better
instead we are choosing a a weekend
where the teams that can lose will
actually advance and none of these games
make any sense and no one's excited
about the pac-12 or cleansing pit or any
of this stuff and you have style points
and everyone arguing it's the simplest
solution at all because the problem with
college football playoff is what
weekend's you run out of weekends with
finals and all this stuff and you don't
want to put the players through a
million games and I get all of that
stuff but we're wasting time with
totally meaningless games this weekend
simply because that's what we've been
doing the last two decades very simple
to get rid of them make more money more
excitement done deal everyone's fired up
well here's my issue with it and I like
it because I agree we you have some
great storylines if you had those games
going into the weekend but the
conference's are too big and you know if
you're looking at teams and say alright
you won the big 10 but if you're not
facing the same opponent as everybody
else in your conference or the
second-place team like I don't know how
you do it where you say all right
Ohio State's the highest ranked Big Ten
team in the final rankings before the
playoffs so they go in Washington would
be the highest ranked team in the pac-12
like how do we get by without having
conference title games here to decide
who goes into the playoffs well they
already they already have the rec like
you know Washington's record is better
than Utah in conference
now you could expand and that make
everyone play nine conference games you
get rid of divisions and have a better
flow of games right now everything's
based like northwestern is only in
because of Geographic welfare right so
they digital every year there's ways to
improve your conference race but in the
case of like where there's actually two
good teams in a conference which it
doesn't happen that often George is
getting in Georgia has a loss in the sec
loss to LSU Alabama has no losses in any
other league like it's your coach and
Little League and your kids in this
thing and they go yeah you have the
better record but we're gonna make you
play
what if cleansed in doing this we get it
what is the point of this Clemson game
they are clearly the champion oh it
actually doesn't happen that often where
you have those historic like we've had
in the SEC right Alabama Florida both
undefeated one two let's do this
but in that case both teams would get
into the end of the playoff anyway but
if you expand it out to nine games you
could solve these problems what you're
getting this weekend is a waste of time
it just does when you have a playoff if
you came from another country you try to
explain this that someone doesn't
understand college football and you're
sitting there Saturday and you're
watching a Clemson game and you're going
oh okay so Clemson needs to win to get
it to advance no not really
they just need to kind of not get blown
out by like 50 points okay so if kick
wins do they get it no they don't get in
well what is the point of this game
alright we know okay so let's say we're
all in agreement here that that this
would be great fans would want it so
what is the hurdle as to why we can't
put this into play I know that there's a
contract you know with the fourteen
playoff with ESPN and you know but
what's the hurry
no college football needs a commissioner
okay
like nobody if you walk if you you and I
Dan go to go to Roger Goodell we sit
down as office and we come up and say
hey here's what we want to do on the
first round of the playoff okay the
divisional games and you're playing on
your stands here's what we want to do
let's just have the Patriots host the
bills and we're going to put this thing
at the Alamodome in San Antonio so
everyone's got travel there and we get
50% of the money what do you think Roger
right throw us through the window and we
land on the street in New York City
there's no Commissioner yes means the
Commissioner Dan well yes peon would
love these games they want these you
know they're hundred million dollar
games these are huge games but each
conference has a commissioner and they
are these guys are older when the next
generation of administrators come you
will see something like this happen the
gym Delaney's the John swafford the Bob
Bowles beast they're not trying to
reform anything they're not that the
fans of like Ohio State fans are going
to lose their
if for a second straight year they don't
make the playoffs they twelve and one oh
hi oh state big bucket hi Big Ten
Champion coached by Urban Meyer doesn't
make the playoffs
Ohio State fans sit there and go this is
not we're one of the best teams what
this is crazy
the big 10 offices sit there and go yeah
we got a great steak last night at
singing elmo's you know like they say
there's no urgency from the
commissioners not these ones now the
next generation there will be but
there's just nobody in charge to say
this doesn't make any sense this does
let's make more money more meaning fire
up the country like again this this
whole week would be about college
football and not hey is Oklahoma better
than Ohio State and like that debate
which is tiring it would be all about oh
my gosh Ohio State's playing Notre Dame
on campus in a playoff game like that's
one of the greatest things we've ever
seen and the excitement of all of that
instead we get this it's like it's
literally like taking the conference
championship games conference basketball
tournaments and saying we're gonna just
do that and then immediately advance the
sweet 16 we're gonna take out the first
few days in the NSA tour because we have
to protect the integrity of the big 12
basketball tournament yeah I guess the
only thing it still comes back to is
these conference championship games
where they're in a neutral site and
those cities lose out on that I don't
know if you could have the first round
of these playoffs where Notre Dame is
playing in Chicago hosting Ohio State or
you know you can have why not look at it
like losing out Tuscaloosa is losing out
those are the cities that sponsor and
support college football all year round
not Miami Gardens not you know not
Indianapolis so you know if you play
these things at home it's a huge event
for these smaller cities so it's but if
you had to you could stage it I mean we
could have a game in Indianapolis I want
in Charlotte on Atlanta and one in
Dallas that's your first four games you
can do that I would just sit there and
say anybody who loves college football
knows maybe the best thing it has going
or it's on campus environments stadiums
are incredible plus home-field advantage
makes the regular-season that what are
we talking about with the NFL right now
the Patriots host Patriots who's getting
home-field advantage
nobody has ever been at an NFL playoff
game
Gillette or Lambeau or hotter anywhere
said man I wish this thing was down in
Tampa I wish we had all had to travel to
Tampa and gone to a game there no you
sit there and go this is the greatest
thing this is awesome we are Heinz Field
for a playoff game now I'm busy Dan
running you know and nationally
you know broadcast a show here so I
don't have time to be able to help you
with this but if if I can you know you
let me know like what would my
assignment be to help put this into
motion you know it's gonna take know get
some coaches involved we need like you
know Saban and Dabo and those guys
behind it hmm
would Saban really want this man you got
Paul which Sabin really want this I
think Sabin what if he isn't meant
they'd have nine eight SEC conference
games it's a big component of that once
he got to what is he got the game is
nothing nothing risk an injury playing
Georgia in a really really tough game
that he actually doesn't have to win
they already wanted to leave all right
well if you if you single out a
conference commissioner and I can get in
Bender's ear a little bit let me know
all right thank you Dan and so Dan
Wesley on who Sports national columnist
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]